when I studied Italian
I always liked reading
about history such as for example the
betrothed also pinocchio what
pinocchio
[Music]
good morning good morning mafia as if one
day you were very well you how are you
very well thanks
today we will talk about  'entrepreneur to
languages ​​and above all italian because
marta teaches italian i don't know not to
say attention attention but 10 and you
teach i can ario six maps to
ask ask for you to make an
introduction of macbeth persist section
mom katie same same
sure then me  my name is marta i'm
italian i
was born in milan and i studied languages
at university because i've always had
a great passion for languages
i had to choose only two languages ​​and i
chose english and spanish
or rather spanish and english spanish before and
after university or i  understood that my
passion was to teach
I naturally took the necessary courses
to become a teacher and well why
sti  6 kind 16 years ago i started
teaching italian as a
foreign language in milan so in a
language school yes a euro school for
adults and teaching italian to
adults yes yes yes in a school through
letters
now yes now yes yes  absolutely then
with the quarantine all the elections
do you think he's going to start teaching
in the more traditional way or he's going to
just continue teaching through
then I think some lessons
will definitely remain online
but simply because the
students are physically far away so
it's impossible but I think that  some
lessons will come back in person if the
students prefer mine at
least yes yes of course it's a social environment
it's a way of being in contact with
other students with teachers that
especially in a group I believe in
one to one
maybe the difference is not  it is a lot but in a
large group the difference is more noticeable
because they can work in a
group more easily  mind in person
obviously if and when I think about
Italian I don't think about grammar I
don't think about the rules of
Italian grammar I think about history I can
think about cooking I can think about
beautiful cities like rome florence and
venice in milan milan perugia but for
but i think about  history why
the influence of italy begins
with rome with well with commercial cities
like genoa and venice with the
renaissance that all this is not
when i studied italian always
i liked to read about the
things about the  history such as
i promessi sposi also pinocchio what
pinocchio of
course i want to say that to prepare
for this interview because i never
speak italian so i speak italian and stay
a little far good he must must
be very good impressive
studied a course at the link which is called
small  straight history of the raid and lara and
culture and fantastic above and explains for
example that the Italian when he was born
the  italian when latin
became italian transforms and the influence
of the tuscan language i
used used for petrarch for danti all
this the cyclones so many things
and just in an appeal fantasti noi and
i listened to a face read during the
two days  well a gp an hour for an hour
a day to prepare our our
our but how good and you when he
teaches Italian what kind of appeal there
are the type of content that you
use or undergo at work
then obviously it depends  from the level
of students in Italian many many
studies these 16 years I have seen that
most of the students are
beginner level or a little more
so when they are of this level
the thing I do mainly is
to motivate them to speak immediately so
that they get passionate about  the language and
therefore I use small techniques such as small
cards, small images that allow us to
use the few things they have learned,
so let's say there are no great
resources  also online I use material
created by me with me so that they can
learn so I have small
conversations with them at the
correct level to stimulate understanding
stimulate production and use the few
words they know a little later
sorry sorry I realized I
realized that I I used a word
that doesn't exist in Italy I said I
took a search of the Spanish and it must
be resources a resource if the
appeal is less not important no because to
communicate understood absolutely
absolutely absolute and this is
another  which I use during
elections I don't interrupt to correct
if we have a conversation
the conversation continues of course there
are exceptions when the
core focus of the conversation is a
grammar topic but generally I
don't interrupt until the end the
conversation has to be natural afterwards
let's see
bravo  yes because you interrupt
the student and to say the thing you
're d  saying it's
not important act no I just want
to correct the Italian but the meaning of
what you say it's not important in
this it's very bad when we agree
with the teachers
and then obviously when the level is a
little higher
let's say in short when people know how to
use they know how to communicate  to talk a little
about everyday things began
to listen to books first listen to
books and then pass more authentic listens
and I suggest for example I don't know news
islo italian when I level a little
higher television programs and then books
there are many resources
as for all  languages ​​resources books
for students of different
levels I suggest then we discuss it together
with a very very good student for example
she speaks very well and
we both watch history documentaries on
rai and then we talk about it together
so you know  as they say a guide a
guide a guide a guide a guide not
just a teacher but a guide
through culture and language  ua
Italian
yes yes yes yes yes very important also then
always put an element in all the
elections then we talk about what
interests the student first of all and
then obviously there is always an element
of Italian culture whether it is
geography or history  is the origin of
something a dish a but also a
word there is always behind a because in
Italian we have
well but bo part and gesticulate and
gesticulate but there are words in
Italian that I want to use better
not for example and that is if  i.e. where you
prefer
so there are things that are and not
to say that more refined there aren't
some things that are more natural I want but it's
a matter of habit of using to
practice but
if there are things that make the
language more more comfortable pm  speaking
and for the others that yes exact and then
also the idioms in each in each
lesson see above all with
higher level students read
each lesson comes out naturally I
then suggest it  erisk a way of saying
an expression a proverb which is
part of our culture and sometimes there
is no translation in the
language sometimes yes this is true for many 5 there
are asp of ex pressures which
exist in this language and not  it has a
tradition but also just words there are
words that sometimes there is not a word in
italian that i believe now i hope
everyone agrees with me the word
sympathetic now you speak spanish so
for for spaniards it is the same or even the
Exact French but for example in
English you change the translation of
sympathetic depending on the sentence of what
you mean because it can be polite it can
be nice hand but it can
also be sometimes it's
nice I always laugh when we're
together yes no yes  there are so many things in italy i don't
have in their own language
in the history of cooking tourism
there are so many things they do
that italian is a link own language
it's worth it
absolutely yes absolut  definitely yes leave
the scene is the list as they say in
italy link the link to your channel the
information for our members who
want to learn accounts with you
achieve with all the
resources we made exactly
exactly in the library yes yes yes
yes
thank you  mille pisa
hello goodbye
[Music]